"According to our information, the enemy has
listed me as target number one, and my family
as target number two.
They want to destroy the country politically,
terminating the head of state."
Desperate words from the Ukrainian president
on the day after Russia invaded his country.
Desperate words from a man who, only a couple
of years ago, played the piano on TV with
his trousers around his ankles …and without
using his hands.
Volodymyr Zelenskyy has undergone an extraordinary
transformation
…from an entertainer dancing in high heels
…to a wartime leader in green khaki t-shirts.
Zelenskyy's regular selfie-style addresses
have won him the eyes and ears, as well as
the hearts, of many at home and abroad.
He has also received standing ovations from
politicians around the world.
Many say that much of his remarkable success
in leading his country against Russia’s
invasion stems from what he says and how he
says it.
But how exactly does Zelenskyy communicate?
Let’s take a closer look.
The skills that are required of playing a
president are kind of the skills required
for the public presentation of a presidency.
It’s now a well-known fact that, before
becoming the president of Ukraine, Zelenskyy
spent a career in show business.
He won Ukraine’s version of ‘Dancing with
the Stars’ back in 2006
…and was the Ukrainian voice behind “Paddington
Bear”.
Zelenskyy went on to star in the satirical
TV show ‘Servant of the People’
where he played a high-school teacher who
is unexpectedly elected President of Ukraine.
I'm convinced that his experience as an actor
is definitely an asset for him.
The ability to have presence, the ability
to remember lines, to read a speech without
it being clear that you are reading, all of
those things from Zelenskyy's prior background
as an actor come into very good use as the
leader of Ukraine.
… abilities that seem more relevant than
ever in the age of digital mass communication.
That’s probably what you need.
You need to be informal, you need to be memeworthy.
“We are all here.
Our citizens are here, our soldiers are here
and we are here.”
Defiant words from Zelenskyy, standing surrounded
by members of his cabinet, after rumors occurred
he had fled the country.
A 32-second selfie-style video, filmed in
the streets of Kyiv – and perfect for going
viral.
What he does with that video is he has all
the tropes that you need to be successful
in the social media age.
It's short, it's informal, it's colloquial.
That's something that they've always been
effective at.
That's why Zelenskyy is the president of Ukraine
– because they were effective in communicating
to young Ukrainians through precisely these
types of social media outlets.
Zelenskyy led an unorthodox presidential campaign
in 2019,
drawing on his fame as an actor.
He gave few interviews and instead relied
on social media.
Literally, within a few months, they had set
up a campaign based around social media using
Instagram instead of Twitter, for instance.
Twitter was something they thought was for
political nerds and journalists.
Instagram was the media to reach ordinary
people who weren't very political and weren't
following the news in much detail.
The strategy proved successful, resulting
in an unexpected landslide victory.
But he failed to deliver on one of his main
campaign promises – to end the conflict
in eastern Ukraine.
And then there were the Pandora Papers.
The investigative report, conducted by an
international network of journalists, revealed
that Zelenskyy had ties to offshore companies.
That didn’t go down well with Ukrainians
given that he had vowed to end corruption.
His approval ratings were rock bottom before
Russia invaded.
But since then, public support for Zelenskyy
has soared to over 90%.
Even people who were definitely his political
opponents before that are giving him recognition
for what he's achieved in terms of the communication
within the country, in terms of his decision
not to leave Kyiv when it seemed in those
early days that Russia would roll into Kyiv
within a matter of days when he told the Americans
that he needed ammunition and not a ride.
“‘To be or not to be.'
You know this is a Shakespearian question.”
“Remember Pearl Harbor, that terrible morning
of December 7, 1941, when your sky was black
from the planes attacking you.”
“Chancellor Scholz, tear down this wall.”
Since the start of the war, Zelenskyy has
been on a virtual world tour,
making his plea for support in front of various
parliaments,
repeating the same message over and over again
– but each time customized for his audience.
When he is addressing a foreign parliament,
he has been primed on the sort of the key
elements of national history that he should
touch upon that will lead his listeners to
identify with the Ukrainian cause in this
particular moment.
And his listeners do seem to identify with
the Ukrainian cause…
Germany for instance reversed decades of foreign
policy and agreed to send weapons to Ukraine.
However, one of Zelenskyy’s demands to foreign
leaders hasn’t been met – his call to
establish a no-fly zone over Ukraine.
Some say that, maybe, Zelenskyy is deliberately
asking for more than he expects to gain – a
strategic communication maneuver.
I think he knows that if NATO was actually
fighting in Ukraine, it would start a third
world war.
But nevertheless, he asked, for example, for
no-fly zones in Ukraine to avoid Russian bombardments.
And in the US, Congress could not offer him
that.
But they decided to send more anti-aircraft
bombs.
And apart from Ukrainians at home and leaders
abroad, Zelenskyy clearly has another target
audience in mind…
“I want to address today the people of Russia.
I am addressing you not as a president, I
am addressing you as a citizen of Ukraine.”
Zelenskyy speaking on the eve of the Russian
invasion,
setting himself apart from Russian President
Vladimir Putin.
He's certainly the antithesis to Putin in
terms of his communication strategy.
So Putin has been giving hour-long lectures
about obscure aspects of Russian and Ukrainian
history.
[...] Zelenskyy has been able to do these
shorter attention-grabbing and spreadable
ideas, much more so than Putin has.
And it is not just his communication strategy
that makes Zelenskyy a counterpoint to Putin.
The Russian president is known for projecting
a kind of hypermasculinity.
The word macho is almost perfectly positioned
to describe Putin because he is very keen
to present himself as shirtless, on horseback
and as an excellent athlete, succeeding at
having power over other people through the
use of his body.
Zelenskyy is not concerned with those things,
and it would be tempting to say that this
is post-masculinity.
But in fact I think it's just a different
kind of way of being a man in the world, one
that is not quite so concerned about maintaining
its dignity and its status as man all the
time.
Zelenskyy has been presenting himself as unshaven,
exhausted, vulnerable – but determined nonetheless.
We look at him and we see someone who is an
ordinary person who's been called upon to
do something extraordinary.
And that, to many of us, feels heroic.
So he is, in an odd sense, heroic precisely
because he's not a natural born hero.
From entertainer to wartime leader – Volodymyr
Zelenskyy has been delivering a compelling
performance in a role he probably never wanted
to play.